this would start little girl lived about
50,000 years ago researchers use DNA
sequencing to map the genes in the same
kind of detail that they can get with
the DNA of living people that map is
giving scientists a clearer idea of how
different kinds of humans evolved little
girl who is about three years old was a
Denisovan Denisovans are one of an
ancient a group of ancient people who
lived in Asia and MCOs cousins of
Neanderthals now most of what we know
about Denisovans comes from a single bit
of a finger burn found in a cave in
Siberia most gene information people is
degraded in a complete but this year
scientists discovered a new method for
working with ancient DNA their study
shows that the little girl had brown
hair brown eyes and brown skin it also
shows that some people in South and
Southeast Asia today have done a certain
genes being that our ancestors interbred
with them now scientists are applying a
new method to other ancient people like
Neanderthals the exciting findings and
the ingenious techniques used to get
them make the Denisovan genome one of
our top ten breakthroughs of 2012